well I heard that there was a 100%
solar-powered train in the world I
thought that's a ridiculous idea of
course solar power isn't enough to move
a massive heavy train there isn't even a
practical solar powered car on the
market and yet here it is
welcome to Byron Bay Australia home of
the byron bay railroad company this is a
70 year old vintage train it was built
in 1949 after the Second World War and
we've converted it now to the world's
first solar-powered train now train
would typically have had two diesel
engines and we've taken one of those out
kept one as a backup and that's been
replaced essentially with the batteries
and a new gearbox in all the control
equipment we have a 70-ton train but in
terms of a full sized train that's quite
light it also renowned to be very quiet
in the industry I'm the train driver of
the only solar train in the world I've
been driving the train from day one
which has been operating for about 16
months now I had my own business for 31
years I sold the business 10 years ago
and basically did myself out of a job
and then this job came along and so I
put my hand up for it and yes
they trained me up and Here I am driving
a train actually driving the solar train
is easier than driving up when it's in
diesel our tracks three kilometres long
and the train goes from byron bay back
to what we call a north beach station
it's got a slight grade up slight grade
down in certain sections so what we do
is we throttle up to get us up to the
first hump in the road and then we Coast
for the next probably half a kilometre
then we throttle back up again to get us
over the next little hump in the road
and that's how we get ourselves into
Byron and doing it that way we don't use
near as much battery power and that's
the name of the games they've the
battery power you've got to remember
that the Train weighs 70 ton so once it
gets up its momentum you've got steel on
steel so it just keeps rolling on we
have regen braking and we use it as much
as possible that throws some charge back
into the batteries every time we use it
the battery on this train is roughly the
same size as you find an electric car it
stores 77 kilowatt
on a run back and forth uses about five
now that means this takes more power
than electric car but not that much more
considering it carries seventy people
the solar on the train works in two ways
we have six and a half kilowatts of
solar panels on the roof of the Train
and then in addition to that we have a
30 kilowatt array on top of the platform
here so the combined there is thirty six
and a half
kilowatts and we can produce on a good
day up to 150 kilowatt hours of energy
the solar panels on the roof of the
train are constantly doing a trickle
charge of the battery on the train and
then a couple of times a day just to top
up the battery we plug it in here at the
platform like an electric car using
electric car equipment this is a net
carbon positive project and in the first
year of service we put 60,000 kilowatt
hours back into the grid on top of the
power that we used it is enough to power
17 three-bedroom houses as an example in
the peak of summer with the low amount
of energy used per trip we can actually
run a whole day service without topping
up the charge just from the six and a
half kilowatt array on the roof of the
Train and the 77 kilowatt battery bank
this isn't something that would work
everywhere or even that should work
everyone the weather here is perfect for
solar power and this is a small
independent railway with one bit of
straight flat track on the train that
can spend some time plugged in for most
railroad companies it'll be a better
idea to add a third rail or some
overhead power lines and run the train
off the regular power grid and then put
some solar panels on the station roof as
well but as a demonstration of what's
possible with solar power and as a neat
way to bring some tourists to your train
line it's a pretty good idea we've been
running for a little bit over a year
we've carried over a hundred thousand
passengers in that time and we haven't
missed a service thanks to all the team
at the byron bay railroad company pull
down the description for more about them
and about this train
you